>> Will Sentance: Vì vậy, bây giờ chúng ta sẽ chuyển sang những gì đã thay đổi trong ES2015 và
trên thế giới.
Thế giới ES6.
Vì vậy, cho đến lúc đó, những gì chúng ta đã thấy ở đây trước đây.
Mô hình này, hãy nhớ rằng mô hình đẹp ở đây chúng tôi đã có?
Đó là khá nhiều đó.
Và sau đó là những lời hứa, và mọi thứ có một chút khác biệt.
Tiền đề cho nó là điều này.
Nếu tôi thử và tổng hợp lại, tiền đề sẽ là cái này.
Khi tôi có mô hình này ở đây, khi tôi sử dụng setTimeout.
SetTimeout có làm được gì trong JavaScript không?
Không, hậu quả của nó là do đâu, Kayla?
>> Kayla: Trong trình duyệt web.
>> Will Sentance: Trong trình duyệt web, ngay tại chỗ.
Nhưng khi tôi đã thiết lập bộ hẹn giờ trong trình duyệt web,
theo dõi thực tế là tôi đã bắt đầu nó, hoặc các tính năng nền khác?
Tôi thực sự không có bất kỳ cách nào để theo dõi điều đó trong JavaScript, phải không?
Trong JavaScript, tôi đã loại bỏ chúng.
Bây giờ, tôi có thể trạng thái console.log Trong dữ liệu JavaScript và JavaScript bằng bảng điều khiển của tôi.
Nhưng tôi không thể đi và hình dung tất cả những thứ ở đây.
Không có bảng điều khiển nào giống như hình dung nó cho trình duyệt web,
đó là một chút cũ, phải không?
Đó là một nửa những gì bạn đang làm rõ ràng hơn một nửa những gì bạn làm trong JavaScript
đang xảy ra ở đây.
Và tôi không theo dõi được nó, không thể duy trì tính nhất quán
giữa trạng thái, dữ liệu tôi thấy ở đây trong bộ nhớ của mình và
những thứ đang xảy ra ở đây.
Không có cách nào để lập bản đồ những gì tôi đang làm ở đây
trình duyệt web với những gì đang diễn ra ở đây bằng JavaScript.
Đó là về lý luận của nhà phát triển và suy nghĩ về những gì chúng tôi đang làm khi chúng tôi
đi và sắp xếp duy trì quy mô ứng dụng không phải là lý tưởng mà tôi sẽ nói.
Và tôi sẽ đặt lời hứa là lời hứa tuyệt đối trong những điều có giá trị nhất
họ cung cấp, họ cũng có tất cả các lợi ích, là một mong muốn nói rằng,
khi bạn kích hoạt một thứ gì đó trong nền, đừng chỉ ném nó ra ngoài đó.
Nhưng nó cũng có một số hệ quả trong bộ nhớ JavaScript.
Vì vậy, tôi có sự nhất quán giữa những thứ đang diễn ra trong nền sẽ
có một số hệ quả trở lại trong Java tại một số thời điểm.
Và bằng cách nào đó tôi cũng đang theo dõi điều đó trong bộ nhớ JavaScript.
Vì vậy, với ES6, chúng tôi đã giới thiệu những gì tôi sẽ gọi là các hàm mặt tiền hai hướng.
Họ không chỉ, chúng ta hãy nhớ trình duyệt web của chúng ta, có gì trong đó.
Chúng tôi có công cụ JavaScript của mình, chúng tôi có JS, công cụ JavaScript của chúng tôi,
và sau đó chúng tôi cũng có rất nhiều tính năng của trình duyệt,
một trong số đó đã nói với Internet về yêu cầu mạng.
Và đó là nhãn của nó.
Chúng tôi có một nhãn trường học cũ, theo cách này hoạt động theo cách giống như thời gian chờ đã đặt.
Lấy một chức năng, ném nó xuống trình duyệt web,
thiết lập bộ đếm thời gian với phong cách trường học cũ.
Chúng tôi có một phong cách mới theo trường phái thiết lập tính năng trình duyệt nói chuyện với Internet,
nói chuyện với Twitter, bất kể nó có thể là gì.
Gửi yêu cầu thêm dữ liệu qua Internet.
Và nhãn cho nó trong JavaScript là tìm nạp.
Nhưng có một cách làm mới của một ngôi sao.
Đó là một chức năng mà tôi sẽ gọi là chức năng mặt tiền hai hướng.
Nó thiết lập một yêu cầu mạng trên web
các tính năng của trình duyệt, tôi tiếp tục làm điều đó.
Trong các tính năng của trình duyệt web, nó thiết lập một yêu cầu mạng ở đây.
Nhưng thay vì chỉ làm điều đó và sau đó không có gì,
không có cách nào để biết điều này được thực hiện trong JavaScript từ đó trở đi,
nó cũng sẽ có hậu quả ngay lập tức trong JavaScript.
Nhãn tìm nạp này sẽ kích hoạt nói chuyện với Internet ở đây.
Gửi yêu cầu mạng, nói chuyện với internet, yêu cầu
dữ liệu từ Twitter ở đây.
Và đồng thời nó cũng sẽ có trong JavaScript,
trong JavaScript land trở lại
một loại đối tượng đặc biệt được gọi là đối tượng hứa hẹn.
Điều đó sẽ nằm trong trí nhớ.
Và khi công việc nền được hoàn thành ở đây, bạn sẽ điền vào và
cập nhật dữ liệu của đối tượng đó với dữ liệu từ nền.
Và bây giờ khi chúng tôi hoàn thành công việc nền của mình,
chúng tôi không ngạc nhiên rằng điều gì đó sẽ có kết quả trở lại
JavaScript vì chúng ta đã có một hàm mặt tiền hai hướng.
Nó đã gây ra hậu quả ở đây, một ngạnh.
Nhưng nó có một hậu quả khác ngay lập tức trong JavaScript.
Một loại đối tượng giữ chỗ nhỏ sẽ cho phép chúng tôi giữ lại
theo dõi bằng JavaScript trong bộ nhớ cục bộ của chúng tôi hoặc trong toàn cầu của chúng tôi
bộ nhớ ở đó về những thứ mà chúng tôi đã kích hoạt ở đây trong trình duyệt web.
Vì vậy, bây giờ chúng tôi đã ánh xạ hai thứ này với nhau và chúng được liên kết mật thiết.
Tính năng nền khi nó hoàn thành sẽ dẫn đến hậu quả
ngay lập tức trả về đối tượng JavaScript.
Chúng ta sẽ thấy nó phát ở đây, nhưng hãy xem nó,
hai hàm mặt tiền được phân bổ đều có thể khởi tạo hoạt động của trình duyệt web nền
là Internet và trả về một đối tượng giữ chỗ.
Nó chỉ là điện tích của vật thể nhưng
một loại đặc biệt với một lời hứa ngay lập tức trong vùng đất JavaScript.
Vì vậy, chúng tôi có một cách để đảm bảo rằng chúng tôi biết những gì đang xảy ra ở đây bởi vì
chúng tôi đã cập nhật nó ở đây.
Thực sự thú vị, là khái niệm rất thú vị.
Vì vậy, chúng tôi bắt đầu.
Chúng ta sẽ thấy nó diễn ra ở đây.
Lưu một màn hình chức năng, hy vọng sẽ được chạy với dữ liệu
quay lại từ Twitter dưới dạng đầu vào, sau đó chúng tôi sẽ có dữ liệu tương lai về nhãn của anh ấy.
Và sau đó ở phía bên tay phải,
từ năm chữ cái mạnh nhất trong JavaScript.
Những gì năm chữ cái đó làm rất phức tạp.
Họ sẽ bắt đầu nói chuyện với Internet.
Năm chữ cái đó thực sự nói với Internet ở đây từ
trình duyệt web.
Không phải trong JavaScript, JavaScript không làm được, nhưng trình duyệt web thì có thể.
Đó là sức mạnh của từ năm chữ cái đó.
Nó sử dụng vô số công nghệ để đi và
lấy dữ liệu từ phía bên kia của thế giới Adrian, JavaScript.
JavaScript không có tính năng đó, tin tôi đi.
Nhưng trình duyệt web có vô số điều đáng chú ý
công nghệ giúp tất cả công việc bắt đầu.
Nhưng nó cũng đồng thời trong JavaScript trả về một đối tượng nhỏ,
đó sẽ được gọi là một đối tượng hứa hẹn, đó chỉ là một đối tượng JavaScript thông thường.
Nhưng có một số tính năng bổ sung nhỏ trên đó, một số tính năng bổ sung nhỏ hai chúng tôi sẽ
xem chúng và cách chúng diễn ra trong chốc lát.